I'm so blessed and I feel so like I'm
never gonna take it for granted because
I knew what it was like to live without
all this Justin Bieber is getting candid
about his past struggles including
issues with family Fame and heavy drugs
this is not the end of Justin Bieber
that's for sure
the singer posted a lengthy and
incredibly heartfelt message to
Instagram on Monday he started off by
writing that he's had trouble getting
out of bed in the morning because he's
been overwhelmed by his past his
emotions and his relationships among
other things quote sometimes it can even
get to the point where you don't even
want to live anymore
Justin acknowledged how grateful he is
for his success and the perks that come
with it but he also called out how
challenging it was being a child star
dealing with the pressure of stardom
it's definitely a hard story he also
wrote about being born to young parents
who separated when they were 18 and had
no money and admitted his whole world
was flipped on its head when he went
from being a 13 year old small-town boy
to a superstar traveling the globe
adored by millions jb says all the
success meant he had people doing
everything for him so he never learned
the fundamentals of responsibility quote
I was a teen with no skills in the real
world with millions of dollars and
access to whatever I wanted at the end
of the day if I'm walking around here
like I'm just everything then that's
when I feel like that's Justin admits to
using pretty heavy drugs starting at 19
and says he abused all of his
relationships revealing that he became
resentful and angry and distant he also
says he was disrespectful to women
thankfully JB writes that it took him
years but he's bounced back he writes
that he's in the best season of his life
yet enjoying marriage with his wife
Haley Bieber
time together he's just really sweet
he's a good kid he's a good heart and I
love it the post ends with some
encouraging words of wisdom Justin wants
everyone to keep fighting even when the
odds are against you I think it's now
about just making good music and keeping
the fans in tune and and not not getting
too ahead of your snot like becoming
something that you're not being being
true to myself always being a good
person because that's always going to
keep my mom happy and make sure that
make sure that I just become a good
person
[Music]